dr anthony fauci's emails emerge and
they are not particularly flattering
and president biden unleashes a tirade
against america to commemorate the 100
year anniversary of the tulsa massacre
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn for peace of mind whenever
you go online visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first have you ever read the
fine print that appears when you start
browsing in
incognito mode online so you think when
you're in incognito mode that your
big tech overlords that they can't view
what you are doing
wrong all of those fine print pieces
what they say is that your activity
might still be visible to your employer
your school or your isp
how can they even call it incognito to
really stop people from seeing the sites
you visit you need to do what i do and
use expressvpn because incognito is not
enough
think about all the times you've used
wi-fi at a coffee shop or a hotel or
even at your parent's house without
expressvpn
every site you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network that is still
true even when you're in
incognito mode your home internet
provider can also see and record your
browsing data in the us they're legally
allowed to sell that data to advertisers
so why not stop them from doing all that
with expressvpn
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
your network data and re-routes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays just
that
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it is super easy to use
the app literally has one button you tap
to connect now you're done stop letting
strangers invade your privacy online
protect yourself at expressvpn.com use
my link
at expressvpn.com pencil get three extra
months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
ben to learn more okay so the big news
of the day
is that buzzfeed has somehow gotten
access well not somehow they they asked
for
a foia request for dr anthony
fauci's emails over the course of the
last year and a half
or so and what emerges is a picture of
anthony fauci that is not
particularly flattering because he
receives a lot of information that he
then
ignored he receives a lot of flattery
from very high-ranking people which he
apparently
sort of took and and stuffed in his back
pocket now the way the media are
treating these emails is that there is
nothing to see here
like nothing at all in fact if you look
at how the media are treating fouchy
they have to continue to burnish his
image as the greatest of all doctors
despite the fact that he has been a
public
health failure in terms of the imaging
and the messages he was trying to convey
to the public
he's flip-flopped on every available
issue from whether schools should be
open
to what the proper methods of social
distancing are so whether maths are
appropriate or not
to whether the vaccines require you to
wear a mask post-vaccination or not
has been all over the place on every
single one of these issues he has not
been
a good public health communicator and he
has indeed reveled in this
the latest news on voucher by the way is
that he is set to release a book on
truth and service
in november so he's about to cash in in
the new book
the director of the national institute
of algae and infectious diseases
shares his views on truth and the
experiences that have shaped his life
philosophy it's only 80 pages
and it's filled with interviews that
vouch has conducted during his 34-year
run
as nia id director the book which will
be released by national geographic books
on november 2nd will discuss how to lead
during a time of crisis
sure to strike a chord with readers the
inspiring words of wisdom in this book
are centered around life lessons
compiled from hours of interviews
offering a concrete path to a bright and
hopeful future
says the publisher meanwhile there is a
children's picture book about voucher's
title dr fauci how a boy from brooklyn
became america's
doctor that is due later this month also
fouch is going to be the subject of a
new disney-backed biopic documentary
that will be released
on national geographic later this year
apparently filmmakers were following
fouchy around throughout 2020 as he
worked on the coronavirus task force
unclear exactly how much he's going to
make from the film or from the books
suffice it to say that fauci has not
been camera shy throughout all of this
now the way that the media are treating
these emails again is that there's
nothing to see here the headline from
the washington post
anthony fauci's pandemic emails all is
well despite some crazy people
in this world fauci's correspondence
from march and april 2020
obtained through the freedom of
information act offers a peek into his
world during the frantic early days
of the coronavirus crisis as the
coronavirus panzer making gulf the world
last spring science magazine quoted
a top chinese health official saying the
united states and other western nations
were making a big mistake by not telling
people to mask up
science magazine stands by its reporting
but the official george gal worried that
the comment might upset
his longtime friend anthony fauci so
amid the deepening crisis gal reached
out to clear the air
i saw the science interview how could i
say such a big word mistake
about others this was journalist wording
hope you understand said gao director of
the chinese
center for disease control and
prevention let's work together to get
the virus out of the earth
i understand completely no problem
without you wrote back we'll get through
this
together about 866 pages of fouch's
emails were obtained by the washington
post
as part of a freedom of information act
request
the correspondence which is just march
and april we don't have anything beyond
that
is um yeah according to the washington
post just demonstrates
how wonderful he was at all of this
he was reached out to by bill gates and
he was reached out to by the medical
director of the
national football league players
association
thought she said in a recent interview i
was getting every single kind of
question
mostly people who are a little bit
confused about the mixed messages that
were coming out of the white house
and wanted to know what's the real scoop
i have a reputation i respond to people
when they ask for help even if it takes
a long time
and it's very time consuming but i do
the released emails show fouchy indeed
try to answer many queries sometimes
hitting send
well after midnight and even as trump
ratcheted up attacks on china for not
containing the virus
that she sought to maintain maintain it
ties with gao a well-regarded chinese
scientific leader and gao with him and
the entire article is about what a
wonderful wonderful
man fauci is and how tolerant he is
and how he shun the limelight which is
pretty incredible for a guy who posed
for instyle
magazine here's another headline from
cnn thousands of emails from and to
fouchy during the pandemics early days
were published
here's what they show about him and the
tweet from
from cnn is absolutely gushing the tweet
from cnn is all about what a wonderful
one
these emails they demonstrate just how
wonderful he is okay so here are some
problems
with the fouchy emails he was warned
about the wuhan lab league theory very
very
very early on in fact it appears that he
was warned in late january
that there were elements of the virus
that looked engineered
there's a woman named christian anderson
i believe a
uh named or could be a gentleman i'm not
sure there's a person
named christian anderson who emailed
fauci
and said thanks for sharing i saw this
earlier today and both eddie and myself
are actually quoted in it
it's a great article but the problem is
that our phylogenetic analyses aren't
able to answer whether the sequences are
unusual at individual residues except if
they are completely off
on a phylogenetic tree the virus looks
totally normal and the close clustering
with bats suggests that bats serve as
the reservoir
the unusual features of the virus make
up a really small part
of the genome so one has to look really
closely at all the sequences to see that
some of the features
potentially look engineered okay this
would be an email
from january 31st 2020 in which
a fellow scientist was telling fauci
that some of the elements of the virus
look engineered
okay on february 1st there were emails
in which fauci apparently
was discussing gain of function research
one of his colleagues over at the nih
guy named hugh
ocean claus emailed him february 1st
2020 saying the paper you sent me
says the experiments were performed
before the gain of function pause but
have since been reviewed and approved by
nih
not sure what that means okay and faucet
wrote back
okay stay tuned so it sounds as though
people were talking about gain of
function research
in the woohen labs apparently as early
as like the beginning of february
in these emails okay he was warned
was fouchy that the chinese were lying
about their numbers by the founder of
biosignal technologies
as of mid-march this person warned fauci
said i'm confident that the china
stopped counting dead at coven 19
infected bodies since about january 7th
2020.
they've been adding fabricated data
daily to show to save face the world in
their own people and impressive
flattening of china's outbreak curve
it's easy to prove this via data
analysis because for example improbable
coincidences occurred in much of the
data my suspicions were eventually
confirmed by at least two of my sources
in china the data posted by china is not
only garbage it has misled the world
into a false sense of security with
regard
to death rate age versus death and other
things okay so fauci was warned again
very early on that the chinese were
lying about their numbers
he was warned again on february 22nd
about the possibility of a lab league
there's a doctor named michael jacobs
who's a cornell medical school
graduate associate professor of
dermatology at weill cornell in private
practice
and he was working with a guy named
alexander tarakovsky who's a professor
at rockefeller university and a variety
and a virologist
he says we have been following the
coronavirus pandemic closely and a few
days ago became alarmed at the news that
the chinese government is sterilizing
their paper money from hubei province
we think there is a possibility the
virus was released from a lab in wuhan
the biotech area of china
we also think the virus might be complex
with another organism such as a yeast or
fungus to make it more sticky
we would like to discuss this with you
further he forwarded this on to his
assistant it did fauci
and said please handle so
he was being warned about the
possibility of gain of function research
he was sending emails about it he was
being warned about china
lying and then he was simultaneously
downplaying
the idea that this thing was made in the
lab you remember that fauci openly
testified that there was no evidence
that it was made in the lab
at all like none he couldn't identify
any
if you look at the evolution of the
virus in bats
and what's out there now it is
very very strongly leaning towards this
could not have been
artificially or deliberately manipulated
the way the mutations have naturally
evolved
someone will say well maybe somebody
took it from the wild
put it in the lab and then it escaped
from the lab
but that means it was in the wild to
begin with nobody's arguing whether it
was
in the wild is like a basic virus but
this this form of cover 19 has never
been found in a bat like ever
okay so that she was being warned about
that in february and he was
simultaneously downplaying
all of this okay later of course fauci
would testify
with regard to covenant in china rand
paul really went after him on this
for years dr ralph barrick a virologist
in the u.s
has been collaborating with dr xi
zhengli
of the wuhan virology institute sharing
his discoveries about how to create
super viruses this gain of function
research has been funded
by the nih dr fauci do you still support
funding of the nih funding of the lab in
wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the
nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute okay well it
turns out that
actually we signed checks to a place
called ecohealth and they signed checks
to the wuhan institute of virology by
best available
data today now of course voucher admits
that china could have used the money for
gain of function research
you gave them money and you said don't
do gain-to-function research
correct and they said we won't correct
and you hate have no way of knowing
whether they did or not
except you trust them is that right well
we generally always trust the grantee to
do
what they say and you look at the
results have you ever had a grantee lie
to you
i cannot guarantee that a grantee has
not lied
to us because you never know okay again
there's an email since february 1st 2020
we need to know what it means
from hugh ocean class saying the paper
you sent me says the experiments were
performed before the gain of function
pause
but have since been reviewed and proved
by nih so what exactly are we talking
about here
not sure what this means since emily is
sure that no coronavirus work has gone
through the p3 framework
she'll try to determine if we have any
distant ties to this work abroad is what
that email says
okay so certainly there should be some
sort of questions asked about all of
this we'll get to
more of anthony fauci and his emails in
just one second
first let's talk about wall street so
wall street has been fibbing for years
saying seven percent is a great return
on your stocks well the folks over at
carnivore trading say it is not
they've also been saying that trading is
so complex you need a financial advisor
but
says carnivore trading you do not real
people are making 30 50
even 100 a year on their money trading
stocks even when the market is tough
carnivore trading is an anonymous team
of elite
wall street strategists they're legends
among wall street heavy hitters and now
they've gone a bit rogue because they
are
opening up their books and allowing
everyday people to see and mirror
their explosive trades if it sounds too
good to be true well carnivore is
actually going to let you see what
they're doing i mean it is fully
transparent they're going to let you see
the trades they are making right now for
free so you can actually
track their performance go to get our
trades.com
use promo code ben get two weeks for
free you actually see what they are
doing on a day-to-day basis
if you join carnivore guarantees you
will get five times your subscription
fee or double your money back
so you really don't have anything to
lose head on over to get our trades.com
promo code ben that's getourtrades.com
promo code ben see website for
guaranteed terms and conditions
past performance is not a guarantee of
future earnings go check them out right
now
get our trades.com okay so anthony fauci
he downplayed the lab league theory all
throughout march all throughout april
and he was thanked
by heads of of these various labs were
doing so
so he so for example anthony fauci was
thanked for downplaying the lab league
theory
by a guy named peter dazzick peter
dashik said
as the p1 of an r1 grant publicly
targeted by fox news reporters at the
presidential press briefing last night
i want to say a personal thank you on
behalf of our staff and collaborators
for publicly standing up and stating
that the scientific evidence supports a
natural origin for covenant 19
from a bat to human spillover not a lab
release from the wuhan institute of
virology
from my perspective your comments are
brave and coming from your trusted voice
will help dispel the myths being spun
about the viruses origins once the
pandemic is over i look forward to
thanking you in person to let you know
how important your comments are to us
all so that was the
head of apparently one of these labs was
passing through funding
thanking anthony fausch for his approach
on all of this
fauci was also thanked by
jin wan zhu who was or wan jiu jin
professor huang zhu zhen
of the institute of zoology at the
chinese academy of science
who was very happy that he had
downplayed
all of the chinese lab league theories
he emailed fouchy dear dr anthony
esfauchi thank you very much for your
hard work on cover 19.
you are the hero of word good times
all right so that's what voucher's
emails show with regard to the lab leak
stuff okay he was being warned very
early on we have some emails that are
internal that suggest that
the lab leak stuff was being passed
around gain of function research
speculation was being passed around
internally
and meanwhile voucher is strongly
downplaying all of that information
so further questions are necessary to
say the least then we get to anthony
fauci
on masks now as we know anthony fouch
has been all over the place
on masks in fact february 5th he sends
an email to sylvia burwell
saying quote masks are really for
infected people to prevent them from
spreading infection to people who are
not infected
rather than protecting uninfected people
from acquiring infection the typical
mask you buy in the drugstore is not
really effective in keeping out virus
which is small enough to pass through
the material
it might however provide some slight
benefit in keeping out gross droplets if
someone coughs or sneezes on you
i do not recommend that you wear a mask
particularly since you are going to a
very low risk location
your instincts are correct money is best
spent on medical counter measures such
as diagnostics
and vaccines okay so he was saying the
same sort of stuff publicly right he was
saying that masks are unnecessary at
this point in time
this is in early february okay and
later of course he would admit that in
march when he was saying don't wear a
mask at the very beginning that he was
fibbing about the masking
i mean fouchy said that he didn't regret
having fibbed about the masking in fact
he told
nora o'donnell quote i don't regret
anything i said then because in the
context of the time in which i said it
it was correct
we were told in our task force meetings
we have a serious problem with the lack
of ppe's
and masks for the health providers who
are putting themselves in harm's way
every day to take care of sick people
when it became clear the infection could
be spread by asymptomatic carriers who
don't know they're infected that made it
very clear we had to strongly recommend
masks
also it soon became clear we had enough
protective equipment and cloth masks and
homemade masks were as good as masks
that you would buy from a surgical
supply store okay well so he just
admitted
again that he lied but you know no
biggie
okay more egregiously fauci's emails
show that he knew
very very early on that once you were
infected you're basically done
right fauci himself explicitly
says that he was that when it comes to
immunity post-infection he said yeah i
think it's there
right so ezekiel emanuel emailed him
zeke manuel of course is one of the
advisors
to biden he was an advisor to obama and
one of the founders of obamacare
he wrote to him on march 4th and he said
is a person likely to be immune once
they caught coveted ones do we know
anything about likely drift
voucher wrote back this is march 4th no
evidence in this regard
but you would assume that there would
that there would be spelled they're
wrong
there would be substantial immunity
post-infection it is an rna virus and so
you can expect mutations but not sure
how much is going on
but then he was out there wearing a mask
like when rand paul was was not wearing
a mask post infection he says i'm immune
now and i'm not passing this thing he
had a teta tet with fouchy on this
particular issue and here's fauci
contradicting himself
what studies do you have that people
that have had the vaccine
or have had the infection are spreading
the infection if we're not spreading the
infection
isn't it just theater no it's not a
vaccine and you're wearing two masks
isn't that theater
no that's not here we go again with the
theater let's get down to the facts
in the south african study conducted
by j and j they found that people who
were infected
with wild type and were exposed to the
variant in south africa the 351
it was as if they had never been
infected before
they had no protection okay so it turns
out of course that rand paul was exactly
correct the only question
with regard to rna viruses is whether
the thing is mutated that fast that you
won't have
some sort of immunity to another strain
but there was no evidence that this was
the case that you were getting the
people were routinely getting reinfected
and there's no evidence of that anywhere
along the line and yet we were still
told that once you had had the virus you
should still be wearing a mask around
finally fauci of course admitted that he
was wearing a mask for no reason
i'm obviously careful because i mean i'm
a physician and a healthcare provider i
am now much more comfortable in
in people seeing me indoors without a
mask i mean
before the cdc made the recommendation
change
i didn't want to look like i was giving
mixed signals but being a fully
vaccinated person
the chances of my getting infected in an
indoor setting is extremely low and
that's the reason
why in indoor settings now i feel
comfortable about not
wearing the mask because i'm fine as we
pointed out at the time when faucet was
saying all of this was nonsense when he
was saying it
and of course he was lying about it but
now we know that going all the way back
to
march of last year he knew that once
you're post infection which also means
post vaccination you really don't need
to wear a mask and for months
we've been told that the responsible
thing to do joe biden said this it was
patriotic for you to mask up
even after you'd had the vaccine and
then of course he switched in time so
the theme here the constant theme from
fauci is that he had very early
indicators of what was going on
and he routinely took the position that
best what upheld what he thought
was the viability of the national
institutes of health in other words
he is a career bureaucrat and career
bureaucrats do exactly what you would
think they do they defend their
institutions
sort of like john roberts with the
supreme court right he'll make a bunch
of bad decisions that are intended to
uphold the veracity of the supreme court
as opposed to just looking at the text
of a particular law
and seeing whether it squares with the
constitution well dr fauci did the exact
same thing with the niaid
right from the very beginning he had
people speculating that this was a wuhan
lab leak and he downplayed that because
it turns out
that there may have been connections
between gain of function research in
china and funding from the nih
we knew at the very beginning that the
that
that masks he thought were actually
useful at the beginning
he thought first they were not useful
then he thought they were useful and he
lied about it
and then he said i don't regret having
lied because after all i was doing the
right thing
we had dr fauci who's fibbing about the
virus itself
and post virus immunity right and all of
this
was designed to set him up as the expert
and meanwhile he was emailing everybody
he knew about all these wonderful
profiles of him
and saying oh man this is just this is
so tough to take you know this publicity
and then he's going and posing for
in-style magazine
so does this say that he's an evil man
does this say that
he's a conspiracist no what it does say
is that like all career bureaucrats he's
a career bureaucrat
and you shouldn't trust these public
health officials to be anything but that
career bureaucrats they are not quote
unquote scientists in the sense they
will follow the science wherever it
leads they are bureaucrats who will do
whatever they have to do to uphold
their institutional prerogatives and
their institutional power
we'll get to more on this in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that the second amendment is super
important and that means of course that
you should own a firearm if you're a law
abiding citizen but
another thing that you should definitely
own is body armor okay you've heard me
share about buying body armor i would
highly recommend you check out ar 500
armor they have loadouts designed for
everyone whether you need a concealable
vest for daily use or a plate carrier
for the range or a fully equipped setup
for the worst case scenario our friends
at ar 500 armor
have you covered okay i've you know if
god forbids when he breaks into your
house it's great to have a gun fantastic
also kind of important you should be
able to protect yourself so god forbid
you get shot
you have some level of protection air
500 armor makes that happen
for you air 500 armor has multiple
packages pre-built for people just like
you
that simplifies the entire process of
purchasing armor they have their
independence day sale going on right now
so you can have your order in before the
fourth of july these sales are up to 50
off select products so get them while
they last they have rifle rated bundles
starting
as low as 99 bucks also i know the folks
over at r500 armor these are great
people with conservative values
supporting them is an excellent thing to
do go to ar500 armor.com
see all their promotions and special
pricing running right now
you can use code ben for 20 off anything
else in their entire store
best of all they have put together some
packages specifically for listeners of
the daily wire so there's something for
everyone at ar500 armor.com visit air500
armor.com
ben use codeben and checkout for 20 off
okay so as i say with dr fauci what did
this really show
it shows that he was not a
forward-thinking creative scientist who
was just following the data
dr fauci was an institutionalist and
groupthink set in in these institutions
and an echo chamber set in in these
institutions lockdowns were the way to
go and it didn't matter whether the data
didn't match the lockdowns
masks were the way to go and it didn't
matter whether the mass mandates were
effective or ineffective
right fauci just followed the crowd he
was a follower he was not a leader when
you're a public health expert
theoretically you're supposed to be a
leader
right you're the person who's supposed
to be speaking truth no matter what and
and the media portrayed him this way
right because trump would say one thing
and then fouch would say the opposite
because his statements were more in line
with conventional thinking
and then he was the hero and trump was
the villain okay but but fouchy never
said
anything that sort of bucked the
conventional wisdom in the name of
science in fact
very early on in the pandemic he was
sending out untrue information
about mixing up case fatality rate an
infection fatality rate he's saying
there was a two percent case fatality
rate
right me and and he was taking that as
an ifr right the difference in a case
fatality rate an infection fatality rate
what percentage of people who are
identified as having this thing die
versus what percentage of people who are
infected die
very very different percentages okay but
bottom line is this if you look at his
emails these are the emails
of exactly what you would think a career
bureaucrat who suddenly was thrust
forward
into the public limelight and took a
series of conflicting positions based on
whatever was the conventional wisdom of
the day
so do i think this makes dr fauci the
world's worst person
no so i think that there's always fog of
war stuff going on in the middle of a
novel coronavirus pandemic sure
i mean just because he received emails
in late january and february saying
you know this could have happened in a
chinese lab doesn't mean that he is
he is forced to say i think it happened
in a chinese lab
but the sort of unequivocal statements
he was making about it that no no
it almost certainly did not happen in a
chinese lab that was unsupportable by
the available evidence
his statements about mass which
flip-flopped all the way around in which
it seems that he knew
pretty early on that that certain types
of masks were effective and certain
types were not
that was unjustifiable he was a
bureaucrat fussing around in other words
he is not the guy to whom you light vote
of candles and yet
the media treat him that way he's gonna
be receiving awards we're going to have
documentaries about him we're going to
have books about him
about a career bureaucrat who kind of
blew it
that's what that's my takeaway here now
there's another takeaway here
which is an email that is at least
partially redacted in this email from
mark zuckerberg the head of facebook
to fauci basically cold emailing him
and zuckerberg talks about how they're
building a coronavirus information hub
that they're gonna put at the top of
facebook for everyone
and he said he wanted to include a video
from fouchy because people trust and
want to hear from experts rather than
just a bunch of agencies and political
leaders now of course the the lie there
is that fauci is anything but
an agency and political leader that's
that's what he is
and zuckerberg offered to do a live q a
and then there's a final paragraph that
is redacted
it's redacted under a trade secrets
reaction
okay and and it's kind of unclear that
the implication
is possible that what this is is
zuckerberg basically offering that
facebook will shut down information that
factory doesn't want distributed because
this was a big problem throughout the
pandemic
if the wh said something and you
contradict it facebook would would ding
you
if you said something and fouchy
contradicted it facebook would ding you
the same thing was happening over at
youtube
two weeks before the cdc reversed its
garbage stupid chart
showing that you couldn't originally
they said even if you were vaccinated
you couldn't take off the mask
indoors and i did a whole episode about
this we removed it preemptively from
youtube because we knew that they would
try to ding us
for having con contravene the wonderful
and incredible cdc two weeks later the
cdc flipped on it
the the notion that you're going to
allow these public health bureaucrats to
control the flow of information
is pretty astonishing but again what
this
what so much of this came down to was
people didn't know who to trust
and the media decided who you should
trust the media decided who you should
trust the media decided you should trust
fauci and you shouldn't trust anybody
else
anybody who contravened fauci was a bad
guy because the media has a simplistic
black and white narrative where they
didn't follow the science they followed
scientific quote unquote institutions
and fauci as an institutionalist only
mimicked what he thought would look best
for the institution namely take
the most cautious possible line yell at
people about reopening schools
tell people it's bad to have open
beaches tell people they can't go
outdoors because they might get infected
outdoor all this kind of stuff
and now the media are sort of admitting
this right now the media are pretty much
freely admitting this so for example ari
melbourne on msnbc
he said yeah yeah you know for for a
year we ignored the lab league theory
which again
what i mean fouchu was made aware of the
lab league theory in late january
late like at the very beginning late
january early february here's harry
melber fully admitting the reason we
ignored the lab league was because of
trump the media had to set up the binary
they needed
a good guy and a bad guy by the way i
was noting this very early on that the
media were trying to split off fouchy
from trump so they could pose fouchy
as the anti-trump voice of science and
trump is the bat bleep looney guy who's
just saying crazy stuff
it turns out half the stuff trump said
was looney and half of it was more
accurate than the stuff that voucher was
saying
and here's arie melbourne saying yeah we
disregarded the lab because trump said
it
on the one hand if the chief and loudest
advocate for something is a race-baiting
liar who lies all the time and has done
things to contribute to for example the
rise in hate crimes
you can understand why people don't want
to get near that and yet
we all i mean the whole world has a
vested interest
in getting all the possible facts about
where this came from
which informs what happened and what
maybe if anything to do about it
okay but you all ignored it because
trump said it maggie haberman says the
same thing over the new york times uh of
course there was groupthink
early on when this happened i think that
there were a number of journalists who
declined to ask questions
uh who were covering specifically the
origins of this virus and i think there
was a there was a twitter group thing
to try to push back on people who raised
questions but at the end of the day
i come back to the fact that there can
be enough enough issues here to go
around
and when you have a president and you
have a secretary of state who say they
have seen evidence
and won't then share it especially when
you know one of them is saying something
like
kung flu uh you're not gonna get given
benefit of the doubt
okay you don't have to give them better
for the doubt you guys could have
investigated but again you had a
narrative and the narrative had to be
preserved so what we see here
is when institutions matter more than
truth things get really ugly this is
true throughout life
throughout life when an institution
matters more than the baseline truth you
end up with falsehood being promulgated
for fauci the institution of the nia a
the niaid and the nih that mattered more
than him following the science for the
media
the institution of the media which was
dependent on the democratic party being
successful
mattered more than following the actual
science
okay and this led them down some pretty
deep rabbit holes okay we're gonna get
to more of this in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that you want
to keep your hair i mean you do
okay the reality is that most dudes are
going to start going bald in their 30s
there is one way to keep your hair head
on over to for hims.com it's your one
stop shop for hair loss and wellness for
men hymns
is helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed medical
providers and fda approved products to
help treat hair loss no more snake oil
pills or gas station counter supplements
prescription solutions backed by science
hymns was created by a guy who knows
some men's health conversations are
easier online and then in person
no more awkward in-person doctors visits
or long pharmacy lines four hems
connects you to licensed medical
professionals online
that could save you hours it's
completely confidential and discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review if they
determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss it is shipped directly
to your door
today hymns is giving you the best offer
yet if you're not happy with your
results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund and
right now my listeners can get their
first visit absolutely free go to for
hymns dot com
slash ben and that is for hims.com
ben prescription products require an
online consultation with health care
provider will determine if a
prescription is appropriate restrictions
apply see website for full details and
important safety information remember
that is for hims.com
ben okay by the way just a quick note on
the institution of science i've been
ranting about this for a while i have a
full chapter in my brand new book the
authoritarian moment on the perversion
of science
and how science has basically become
institutionalism
great sort of addendum here from the
scientific community my wife at ford
afforded me this story yesterday of
course being
a doctor and in the scientific community
the editor of the medical journal jama
has now been forced to step down from
his job according to robbie whelan at
the wall street journal why did he do
something anti-scientific no of course
not
he's being forced to step down from his
job because he contravened politically
correct notions
accidentally according to the wall
street journal the editor-in-chief
of the journal of american medical
association one of the country's
preeminent medical research journals is
stepping down
after the publication produced a podcast
episode and a tweet that questioned the
existence of racism and medicine
you're not even allowed to question it
you're not even allowed to question
whether your doctor is racist he is
racist and if you'd say otherwise you
get fired from your job at the head of
jamma
on february 24th jem's official twitter
account posted a message
that read in part no physician is racist
so how can there be structural racism in
healthcare
the message urged readers to listen to
an episode of a jama podcast hosted by
edward livingston a top editor at the
journal in which according to several
news reports he said many people like
myself are offended by the implication
that we are somehow racist
the jama tweet went viral and and it
along with the podcast discussion
provoked widespread indignation on
social media and among research doctors
some of whom pledged to boycott jama by
refusing to submit papers to the journal
or provide peer review
for its publications howard bochner a
pediatrician at bu
who has edited the journal since 2011
was placed on leave in march and now he
has been fired
the institute for anti-racism and
medicine a non-profit that promotes
racial equity issues
and professionally useless people
circulated an online petition calling
for a formal review of dr boucher's
handling of the incident
the petition garnered more than 9 000
signatures
they deleted the podcast episode
completely the tweet was deleted as well
instead dr bachener put up a recording a
forced malice struggle session when she
said racism and structural racism
exist in the united states and in
healthcare and then he was forced to
resign
so what exactly was the scientific
evidence that was shown
for him to remove an entire podcast
episode discussing this crucial issue
there was no scientific evidence that
was provided he was just forced to step
out
again institutions exist in every area
of american life and if the institution
outweighs the truth
and bad things happen you're seeing this
happen inside the american psychological
association where they are completely
redefining terminology
in order to meet with woke standards
you've seen this inside the american
medical association
where there have been calls to get rid
of concepts like biological sex
for some radicals because they wish to
redefine gender
you've seen this happen inside now jama
the most prestigious journal of american
medicine there is
and of course it happened with regard to
the coronavirus
19 it happened with regard to covet 19
when the institutions of american life
decided
for example that it was perfectly
acceptable for you to be out in the
streets on mass
protesting for george floyd's death you
just couldn't be out there
going to church outdoors right it was
very important
the science trumped what was trumped by
tough science
right institutional science again
there's a reason why i should pick up my
book the authoritarian moment i have a
full scale discussion of all of this
kind of stuff and again when you respect
institutions
as opposed to the truth you're doing so
because you believe in particular
narratives
you believe that certain narratives have
to remain the truth even if the data
don't support them the
the troublesome thing about science is
that if science is truly about data
if data is what matters in science then
all data does is going around debunking
things
right data is basically the socrates of
modern life it goes around
asking serious questions and then
debunking everybody's narratives
debunking everybody's ideas but what
happens when science gets hijacked
well when science gets hijacked by the
narrative then science is no longer
science
more than that there's now a push in
american life to get rid of science as a
whole
so science has been thrown out the
window in many of these cases but not
just that
there's been an issue with data if you
collect data this is considered racist
in certain circumstances
because the narrative matters more than
anything else because the narrative
allows you to achieve
power and power is the goal we'll get to
that in just one second because that
brings us to
president biden's speech in tulsa first
let's talk about the office chair that
you are using so you're sitting for
hours a day in your office
right and let's face it that thing it
ain't that comfortable you haven't
thought about in a while but really
you're constantly shifting you get home
your back hurts it really is not what
you want to be sitting in
what you need is the greatest chair of
all time
it's like king david's throne it's
unbelievable i'm talking about
the x-chair the secret is not only their
patented dynamic variable lumbar support
which offers
unbelievable lumbar support to your
lower back now thanks to their new xhmt
technology you can also get heat and
massage therapy while you are sitting at
your desk
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair now you can look forward to
spending hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager
the xhmt delivers heat and massage
technology right to your core
helping increase blood flow muscle
recovery and energy all perks that make
working from home
or the office an absolute joy x chair is
on sale right now for 100
off it's so good we have one in the
production room let me just tell you
basically their fist fights every
morning over who gets to sit
in the x chair go to xchairshapiro.com
now that's the letter x
chair shapiro dot com or call one eight
four four
four x chair x chair has a thirty day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
thirty bucks a month
go to exchange shapiro dot com right now
use code x wheels for free x wheel blade
casters xchairshapiro.com
for the world's greatest office chair
alrighty we're going to get to more in
just
one second including an old man shouting
at racist clouds
first from totalitarian lockdown
measures to the blatant indoctrination
of school children into leftist ideology
every day freedom is under assault which
is why i wrote the authoritarian moment
and you should go pre-buy it right now
okay the authoritarian moment goes
through every institution in modern
american life and explains
how those institutions were hijacked by
the left and
explains how we can take back those
institutions or compete with those
institutions or overcome that
institutional power
the authoritarian moment goes through
everything from again the lockdowns
pushed by non-science to the takeover of
america's educational institutions
to corporate wokeness and goes through
and it gives you
a way to arm yourself against woke
ideology
and ways to fight back practical ways to
fight back and shut them down pre-order
my new book the authoritarian moments
now at amazon barnes and noble or any
other major bookseller you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay so meanwhile joe biden was down in
tulsa oklahoma he was paying homage
to the 100-year commemoration of the
tulsa massacre
which we talked about yesterday and i
think in order to understand
joe biden when it comes to race you have
to understand that the entire democratic
party right now
has decided to central centralize they
decide to central all their attention
around a new definition of racism
their definition of racism is anything
they don't like now that's been their
definition for a while but their new
theory is that all the institutions of
american life are shot through
with racism and they never have to
define racism see you and i could define
racism pretty easily because we speak
the language of english
racism means that you believe in the
superiority or inferiority of people
based specifically on their race that is
the definition of racism
but the left doesn't believe in that
definition because if that's the
definition then racism
has been alleviated largely over the
course of american history
right particularly over the last 60
years most americans understand that to
believe such things
is considered evil in our society right
to be an actual honest-to-god racist who
believes in the inferiority of somebody
based on race
is something that is not even considered
remotely within the bounds
of the rational in modern society and in
modern discourse so what did the left
have to do
instead they had to say well the
institutions of america are shot through
with racism
and we don't actually have to define
that we're just going to say it
and then if you don't understand what
we're talking about we're just going to
say it again so the great
sort of prevaricator about this sort of
stuff and popularizer of this sort of
nonsense is ibra max kennedy so
ever max kennedy is a professor at
boston university which is insane and
demonstrates the uselessness of higher
education
he's also the head of what is called the
center for anti-racism research which
today has provided zero research so far
as i'm aware but has taken in
literally tens of millions of dollars
from major institutions including 10
million dollars from jack dorsey of
twitter
just last year for brilliance like this
so here was ever max kennedy this is i
believe a couple of years ago at the
aspen ideas festival he was asked
explicitly
how do you define racism and here is
ibrahmax kennedy attempting to define
racism
this is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard but this is the basis for race
ideology on the left today
so racism i would define it as a
collection
of racist policies
that lead to racial inequity that are
substantiated by racist ideas
and anti-racism is a pretty simple using
the same terms
anti-racism is a collection of
anti-racist policies leading to
racial anybody wants a guess equity
that are substantiated by anti-racist
ideas okay this is
the fact my favorite part of this is
where he he kind of arches his eyebrows
because he said something quite profound
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard in my life the reason it's the
dumbest thing i've ever heard in my life
is if somebody asks you to define a term
and then you use the term in the
definition you have not defined the term
i'm holding a pen right here
if you said define a pen and i said a
pen is a pen
you'd be like that added no new
information i have no idea what you're
talking about if i said to you define
racism and you said
racism is a thing that is racist because
it is motivated by racism you'd be like
i don't know what you're talking about
because that didn't add any new
information
ever max kenny says this says this crap
with a straight face
and everybody just goes oh ah okay but
this provides the basis for democrats to
say
that any inequality of outcome is
representative
of racism in the system and this has
been imbibed
at the deepest level by the democratic
party so that was the purpose of joe
biden going to tulsa
it wasn't just to provide some sort of
commemoration for an evil
of an evil event in american life it was
to say that that evil event is
indicative
of what america was and remains with
regard to black americans
so joe biden goes down to tulsa oklahoma
first he has a fight with his
teleprompter
i mean this is just requisite just as
like an opening as an opening move
as an opening gambit in every one of his
rallies he actually brings out the
teleprompter and then he physically
spars with it so here is
joe biden versus the teleprompter as
always a belief
enforced by law by badge
by hood and by noose that speaks
to that lit the fuse
it lit it by the spark that it provided
a fuse a fury
was an innocent interaction that turned
into an
ins in terrible terrible headline
allegation
yeah man teleprompter puts joe down for
the count as always
but the real purpose here is to conflate
two ideas
idea number one is that we should come
to grips with america's history of
racism
obviously true we should pay attention
to things like the tulsa massacre
because that is a part of american
history that was neglected
in education for a very long time my
guess is that only in the last few years
have most americans even been made aware
of the tulsa massacre as opposed to like
the civil war or as opposed to world war
one or world war ii
but the reality is that that is a fairly
and that's good i'm glad more people are
aware of the tulsa massacre
now that that is a very good thing but
the idea is that if you
are opposed to the racialized agenda of
the biden administration if you say
things have kind of changed between 1921
and 2021 which they most indubitably
have
then this means that you want to deny
history so here was joe biden
doing exactly performing exactly this
sort of conflation here was yesterday
saying that america is great because
we're coming to terms now with our dark
side
we should know the good
the bad everything
that's what great nations do they come
to
terms
with their dark sides and we're a great
nation
alrighty so um we're coming to terms
with our dark side but what he means by
that is that we are going to
fundamentally shift the way
that institutions are run in the united
states in a racist fashion
so biden says americans think that if i
hold you down i lift myself up this is a
pretty wild statement
for too long we've allowed a narrowed
cramped
view of the promise of this nation to
fester
the view that america is a zero-sum game
where there's only one winner if you
succeed
i fail if you get ahead
i'm fall behind if you get a job
i lose mine and maybe worst of all
if i hold you down i lift myself up okay
how many americans believe that right
now like truly how many americans
believe that how many
americans are like he's saying that
americans today are malevolent
right too many americans believe that i
have to hold you down in order to lift
myself up so americans are really really
bad people like today
not in 1921 today americans are terrible
not only that joe biden said that white
supremacy is the greatest threat in
america today it is the greatest threat
in america today
now here's the thing white supremacists
horrible people believe
horrible things no one has been more
critical of white supremacists than i
have
i've been personally targeted by white
supremacists the fbi arrested a white
supremacist a couple of years ago trying
to kill me and my family
okay so white supremacist and i not
friends also
he conflates white supremacy with pretty
much everything he doesn't like and this
is part of the danger how many headlines
have you seen in the media
recently saying things like healthcare
disparities are a result of white
supremacy
right how many times have you seen
members of this administration
talk about how inequal
unequal outcomes in the justice system
are the result of white supremacy as
opposed to you know individual action by
people of different races
okay so here is joe biden laying it out
there here we go
as i said in my address the joint
session of congress according to the
intelligence community
terrorism from white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
that's not me that's the intelligence
community
under both trump and under my
administration okay so first of all if
he just wants to say
that that white supremacist terrorism
happens and is threatening
that's okay i have no problem with that
but if the argument is the most lethal
threat to americans today
is white supremacist to terrorists that
is not true by any statistical measure
of which i am aware
the most lethal threat to americans
today like overall
or the most lethal threat to america
today that's overall all of this is
driven by an agenda
right the agenda is that joe biden wants
to radically remake america's
institutions
he doesn't have to provide data he
doesn't have to provide an actual
argument he just throws out imramx candy
style circular reasoning and then you're
just expected to accept it
that's the reason he was in tulsa it was
not just to commemorate it was obviously
to provide the predicate for shifting
america's institutions
and our notions of individual rights
versus the government alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of content in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show he
discusses the us flying the pride flag
at the vatican is an amazing thing i
don't think they did this
in saudi arabia by the way you can hear
more details about that story over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam's sci events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
biden claims that white supremacy is the
top threat against the united states
gender nullification surgery flattens
people's genitals and turns them into
real-life ken dolls
and the us flies a gay pride flag at the
vatican
check it out on the michael knowles show